and and the thing that I you know I try
explaining people is fame is a hack for
time fame is a hack for time if I have
to sit up here and explain to you well I
know this woman and she's a very good
person she's you know very beautiful
she's married to a hip-hop person she's
you know good entrepreneur shoe if I
could just say Kardashian you know
exactly what I'm talking about it took
me three seconds and then I can move on
with the conversation so being
well-known in an economy that's we're
basically time and attention are the
biggest commodities like the most
precious thing of money there's a lot of
money can't get to a half time you got
tons of money even rich people though
are time poor the richest people in the
world are some of the most time poor and
so if you have to deal with that
condition of the digital civilization
you live in and Fame is just a hack for
time so I can now say yang gang on a
subway and everybody knows what I'm
talking about
and that's for me useful um the more
people who know about you the easier my
job is because I'm trying to promote
positive solutions and yet there's this
you know worship of attention and
celebrity and also an understandable
fear of it because it can be corrupting
it can be isolating it does make you
know my life is very different now that
I'm a relatively well-known person at
least among news nerds than it was
before you know and so yes it there's a
danger there but the bigger danger is
that people with great ideas never get
heard because we are only willing to
speak you know to our own small Twitter
followings and in our own Facebook
groups and we're just afraid to walk on
that big stage and I think that hey
listen if you create a situation where
there's some you know younger fresher
more edgy less you know CN n ready
voices but are still in harmony then the
movement continues to grow even if some
people are more disaffected with you but
like other people who are like you who
are just maybe a little bit more you
know you know grassroots but listen I
don't think that people like you can
afford to keep your light under a blue
you